.
JOHN.
>> CASEY STEGALL IN DALLAS.
TOM HOMAN IS HERE, THE FORMER
ACTING I.C.E. DIRECTOR AND FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WE WILL PUT A LITTLE BOX WITH
THE BUS TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THE BUS IN THE NEXT LITTLE
WHILE.
LET ME TO GET YOU TO TACKLE TWO
TOPICS.
THE IDEA THAT KAMALA HARRIS
HATED THE IDEA OF BORDER CZAR,
DID NOT LIKE IT, AND THE FACT
THAT THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS ARE BEING RELEASED INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
I'M SURE PEOPLE SOUGHT -- SOUTH
OF THE BORDER ARE, THEY ARE
ROLLING OUT THE WELCOME MAT.
>> MOST QUALIFIED?
LIMB -- VOTED TO LIMIT -- YOU
CAN'T NAME ONE THING THEY HAVE
DONE TO SLOW THE FLOW OR TO
SECURE THE BORDER AND AS FAR
AS -- WHEN YOU SAW, THERE IS NO
LACK OF DETECTION BEDS.
WE JUST FINISHED LAST FISCAL
YEAR.
FUNDED FOR 34,000 BEDS.
THE AVERAGE DAILY POPULATION IS
19, LEFT 25,000 BEDS EMPTY.
THOSE BEDS TURN OVER EVERY 30
DAYS, SO DO THE MATH.
THAT'S -- THAT'S, YOU KNOW --
35,000 BEDS TIMES -- 350,000
BEDS THEY COULD HAVE FILLED OVER
TIME.
>> John: AND WHAT HAPPENED TO
REMAIN IN MEXICO?
WE ARE SEEING A LOT OF SINGLE
ADULTS HERE THAT ARE BEING
RELEASED INTO THE COMMUNITY.
I THOUGHT THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO
BE STAYING IN MEXICO.
>> THAT'S ANOTHER THING.
WE HAD TO SUE THEM TO PUT REMAIN
IN MEXICO BACK.
I WAS A PART OF THAT LAWSUIT.
AND WE WON, AND THEY APPEALED IT
SO IMPLEMENTING IT ABOUT 10% OF
WHAT WE DID, THEY HAVE ONLY
REMOVED A FEW HUNDRED, THE COURT
NEEDS TO COME BACK IN AND HOLD
THEM IN CONTEMPT.
THIS ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT
CARE ABOUT THE LAWS OF THE
COUNTRY.
>> John: THE STATISTICS DON'T
LIE.
THIS IS CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PATROL ENCOUNTERS FOR THE MONTH
OF FEBRUARY.
2022, 164,973 PEOPLE WERE
APPREHENDED AT THE BORDER.
THAT COMPARES TO 101,099 # --
AND 36,000 IN 2020.
>> WE ARE ON THE PATH TO BEAT
LAST YEAR'S NUMBERS.
THE NUMBERS ARE -- LAST YEARS
NUMBERS WERE HISTORIC.
HIGHEST ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
NUMBERS IN THE HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY AND WE ARE ON A GLIDE
SLOPE TO BEAT LAST YEAR'S
NUMBERS.
NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE IT AND
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
NOTHING TO ADDRESS IT OR TO
STOP, OR CONTROL THE BORDER.
>> John: LAST TIME WE HAD YOU ON
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE I.C.E.
REPORT, THE AGENCY YOU USED TO
HEAD UP, TYPICALLY RELEASED IN
EARLY DECEMBER.
IT WAS FINALLY RELEASED ON MARCH
11, FRIDAY, IN THE MIDDLE OF A
WAR, GREAT PLACE TO HIDE NEWS.
2021 ARRESTS, 74,082.
THAT COMPARES TO 103,603 ARRESTS
IN 2020, AND 143,000 IN 2019.
DEPORTATIONS, 59,011 IN 2021,
AND 2020, 2019, 267,258.
I.C.E.'S MISSION IS BEING
DIMINISHED HERE.
>> WHEN I WAS DIRECTOR WE
ENFORCED THE LAW.
REMOVED ALMOST 1 MILLION ILLEGAL
ALIENS.
SECRETARY SAYS REPRIORITIZING TO
CONCENTRATE ON CRIMINALS, WRONG.
LOOK AT THE REPORT, REMOVED
48% -- REMOVED 64 -- 54% LESS
CRIMINALS THAN WE DID LAST YEAR
AND ARRESTED 48% LESS.
TO SAY THEY REPRIORITIZED TO
FOCUS ON CRIMINALS WAS A LIE.
THEY ARE ABOLISHING THE MISSION
OF I.C.E. AND THAT SHOWS IT.
I.C.E. IS INEFFECTIVE.
>> THE TWO LINES ON THE GRAPH
BOTH GOING UP, THE NUMBER OF
BORDER ENCOUNTERS AND THE
REDUCTION IN ENFORCEMENT, WHERE
IS THAT GOING TO TAKE US IN THE
NEXT 12 MONTHS?
>> AGAIN, I'VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS IN MY CAREER.
THE LESS PEOPLE I.C.E. ARRESTS
OR REMOVES, ANOTHER MAGNET FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THEY THINK THEY CAN COME TO THE
COUNTRY AND NOT BE ARRESTED OR
REMOVED.
BECAUSE MAYORKAS SAID IT'S NOT
ENOUGH TO BE ARRESTED.
COME TO THE UNITED STATES,
VIOLATE THE LAW AND YOU WILL NOT
BE ARRESTED OR REMOVED.
>> John: TOM, I HAVE A SENSE
WE'LL SEE MORE OF YOU IN THE
MONTHS AHEAD.
>> LET'S HOPE TO.
WE HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT'S GOING ON.